there's a lot of things that get said in
the bitcoin community you know things
like bitcoin is inevitable have fun
staying poor and many other bombastic
and sometimes hilarious comments now of
course every time someone hears one of
these they always wonder what the hell
are these people talking about do they
actually believe what they're saying
recently there's been a bunch of people
have been asking did michael saylor
really mean what he said when he said
that you should mortgage your home to
buy more bitcoin but it wasn't just
people on the internet yesterday he was
on fox business and charles payne asked
michael saylor on live national
television hey michael did you go too
far what exactly were you talking about
here here's exactly what michael
sailor's response was so you you've been
seen as as the sort of pied piper of
bitcoin and some people are suggesting
that maybe you've gone too far that
you've been irresponsible for like for
instance suggesting people mortgage
their homes and businesses i want to
share sought a sound bite with you in
the audience and then get your your
feelings on that
and if you absolutely love the thing
that you're that you don't want to sell
it go mortgage your house and buy
bitcoin with it and if you've got a
business that you love because your
family works for the businesses in your
family for 37 years and you can't bear
to sell it
mortgage it finance it and convert the
proceeds into the hardest money on earth
which is bitcoin
so there are people i respect who say
you go too far with those kind of
proclamations what do you say
well you know the critics always cherry
pick and and they beat up on you at
certain times but if we step back uh the
argentine peso lost 99.5 percent of its
value over 20 years and the only way you
could survive is by going into debt and
converting into a different currency
um the 30-year uh 30-year mortgage you
could get one for 275 basis points a
year ago right now it's 580 basis points
so so telling someone to get to take a
30-year mortgage when you could get one
for half the current price for the rest
of their life isn't bad financial advice
it's a it's a lost opportunity if you
didn't get that cheap money long-term
government subsidized that's a
reasonably good thing
if you step back and look at the big
picture from first principles like
bitcoins up 52
on average per year for the past two
years for the last five years it's a 51
arr for the past 10 years it's 124
percent
and that's 10x better than nasdaq over
the past two years so
you know there's no statutes to critics
i think that the critics need to give
people a solution to their problem and i
think if if the inflation rate is higher
than the interest rate
you would rather be a debtor than a
creditor
and a person's just got to take a long
view look out over the decade and ask
themselves
you know how do i want to be positioned
financially and if you can do that there
are opportunities now my big takeaway
from this is although there's plenty of
bombastic things that are said and many
headlines that you may read and be like
wow i didn't expect someone to say that
usually what occurs is that the people
who have spent tons of time researching
and doing their homework who have
invested millions hundreds of millions
sometimes even billions of dollars into
this asset they've actually done the
work they do have very nuanced
thoughtful and intelligent ideas that
support their takeaway claims now of
course that's not always true and you
should do your own research there is
risk and all sorts of different
financial assets but seeing something
that catches people's eye like hey you
should go mortgage your home to buy
bitcoin that sounds kind of crazy but
once you hear michael saylor actually
articulate exactly what he meant and why
he thinks that and then to look back
over the last two years and explain why
it probably was a good idea then it
becomes obvious that sometimes the
internet it's really really good at
catching all of the crazy stuff on the
internet you see things go viral you see
things taken out of context but at the
end of the day if you sit down and you
have a longer conversation with these
individuals you begin to understand
there's a lot more substance that may
appear at the surface hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time